hey everybody and welcome to a very
special wild ride
this week we have got an icon
a legend of comedy and
marijuana culture plus here's something
you have never heard me say about the
wild ride podcast
this episode has the craziest
celebrity stories ever told by a guest i
mean
it is mind-blowing like the stories that
we are told celebrity after celebrity
after celebrity in the craziest
situations i mean dude perhaps the most
entertaining podcast we've ever recorded
so you're in for a treat ladies and
gentlemen
tommy chong yeah thank you
thank you please no no applause
dad what an honor man and i want you to
meet my co-host
scott randolph how's it going tommy hey
scott
nice to meet you also up at the front of
the van we've got
uh the gorgeous paul briskey hey what's
up tommy how are you
hey paul i don't see you but i imagine
you're gorgeous oh yeah
he sounds great too i'm working on
sounding better myself i've been taking
vocal coaches to try to
make my own good for you yeah make my
voice sound a little more healthy i
don't know
how much can you try it out right now i
am
we've met before tommy um you were doing
a podcast for a bit there
and uh our mutual friend eli
was the one who set it up right i
haven't heard from eli is he still alive
yeah who knows man who knows he might be
he might be back on the skids
uh we we actually spoke to eli he said
that uh we love eli
yeah we love eli and uh he gave us all
kinds of
inside information about you said ask
you
he said to ask you about uh meeting
muhammad ali
john
when was that oh it was
during the when he was uh doing
speech you know when he was uh barred
from boxing
and he was uh just doing talks you know
he was uh tripping around and
yeah yeah that was very funny i got a
friend a dancer friend of mine
scarlett was her name i i played one
time played in a
little circus and she was in one of the
dancers
and so we were friends and she and so i
told her i was going to
uh detroit
yeah i was on my way to detroit and i
was this was in san francisco
and so she told me oh she says oh you
won't you'll no
won't believe who i who i was with who i
was
hanging with last night and i said who
she goes muhammad ali
i said oh great how old did she go you
know it was
it was muhammad ali he's the camp of the
world
yeah so then so then i get to detroit
and bobby
taylor calls me on the phone he goes hey
you want to meet the champ
and what yeah muhammad ali he's coming
over he's coming over
so come on back so so i got my car and i
drove
and parked got in the elevator and
there's muhammad ali in the elevator
and he doesn't know me and you know and
so we're riding up to the
to the bobby taylor floor and uh
muhammad lakes can oh he's not even
looking at me you know kind of
looking over me you know did that
and so i said uh
scarlett says to say hi
there just hit me and him in the
elevator and his eyes got all
big and he looked at me like
i was you know something magic happened
you know
because what are the odds of being in an
elevator
with some guy that knew about your
little affair that you're trying to keep
quiet from the world
[Laughter]
that's cool the next thing you know
you're in the elevator and the guy goes
zayn scarlett says hi
well he just just stared at me just
stared at me and then we got off the
elevator
and we're going to the same room place
because he's
going to meet bobby taylor him and bobby
were friends uh
during the olympics and so so then bobby
introduced us
you know and muhammad ali he then he
started
loosening up he was very happy then it
was very funny and i took pictures with
him but
you know no one no one knows where the
pictures are now there
they disappeared did you guys share a
marijuana cigarette
no no no no bobby wasn't smoking no
no one was really smoking back then just
me you know i'm by myself
you know you know it was highly well you
know imagine he's on
you know he's barred from boxing and he
didn't want to have to
deal with a drug wrap too you know right
was he he was barred from boxing for
like not joining the vietnam war or
something like that or what was that
yeah yeah yeah yeah he uh he wouldn't he
wouldn't
uh yeah he wouldn't do the draft
thing and and he encouraged a lot of
people to burn their draft cards cheats
was one of them
saw muhammad ali and then he burned his
drop card
and then he went up to canada so yeah we
got little
little in-house uh connection there you
know
that's cool is that how you ended up
meeting cheech is that he burned his
draft card
and then went to canada and then you met
him yeah
yeah all because of muhammad ali
[Music]
all because of the girl yeah scarlett
dude
right yeah that's a special girl
scarlett she's still she's still cool
she's
she's she's a buddy of mine you know
what about the time
what about the time you met michael
jackson
michael jackson well michael
we met michael in chicago at the regal
theater
him and his band had won a contest
at the high school and the winner
got to uh open for
uh bobby taylor in the vancouvers
and uh jerry butler it was a double bill
or triple bill with uh the jackson five
and that was the first time we saw him
and
oh man it was like seeing
it was incredible here's this little guy
who's the littlest guy you ever saw
and he's he's acting like uh a
seasoned performer you know he's doing
all the dance steps
he was a big jackie wilson uh fan
so michael doing all the steps and then
they sang
my girl you know the temptations
and oh they were incredible and so and
we shared a dressing room
and so there we are and michael used to
get a little
coca-cola car case you know turn it
upside down and
stand on it stand in the mirror and
you know comb out his uh his little
little natural you know he's in there
he was he was a cool guy and bobby uh
you know bobby taylor who's
yeah we had a hit record and you know
that's why we were on motown
and uh bobby uh
he's the kind of guy you know hey come
on uh
come on to detroit that's what he told
jackson five
and joe come on detroit you stay at my
place you know
we'll we'll get you into motown we'll
[ __ ] you with motown
they did yeah they did so uh
yeah yeah we knew michael before anybody
before barry gordy before anybody wow
wow that's cool you're like forced gum
in your life like
weaves through all this history i am
totally totally uh my all my whole life
has been been like that
you know i've been uh
i've been uh doing that um
yeah meeting people yeah very
serendipity
you know a lot
did you meet prince before he was famous
too i
no he was famous when i i didn't meet
him
talk to him but i was at a at a club
with him one time he's he's
funny guy prince
[Music]
he was he was the shortest guy that ever
saw him with heels
that's cool i i i i
met prince one time i was with the i was
with this girl
you know she was my girlfriend and uh
and i i used to routinely perform tricks
for people when i met them you know if i
really wanted to impress them
so i said let me show you this great
trick i'm going to balance this drink on
my head and then i'm gonna drink it
without using my hands
and i lay down on the ground and pick
the pick up the drink off my head with
my knees and put it down pick it up with
my teeth
and he turns to my girlfriend and he
says
does this impress you like in the most
like
in the most condescending like frankly
dickheaded way
wow and i was like man prince is a dick
right
so then fat fast forward all these years
right first fast forward all these years
we're on tour
and i'm promoting my show in a radio
station
and uh the radio dj just says he says oh
so
you ever made a celebrity that was a
real dick to you and i'm like yeah
prince was it totally a dick i walk out
of the
the the [ __ ] radio station and we go
to the supermarket
and then we find out prince just died
like i was talking [ __ ] about him like
like the day he died yeah that's not
good
i know but but hate me i wasn't like
have to get anybody i was just telling
the story
[Laughter]
he was kind of like the chappelle
character where he's just like uh
you know pass the ball charlie murphy
you know just kind of yeah
for sure i'm sure it's fine plus you
can't make everybody happy if anybody
knows that it's me
i'm sure tommy knows that yeah you ever
pissed anybody off tommy
every uh celebrities me yeah
tommy chong is going to blow you away
with the story he's about to tell
and i might just be about to save you
from pissing someone off
by sharing an incredible deal from
manscaped
because let me tell you when a lady goes
down and finds a big nasty
bush in your nether regions she gets
pissed off and
off a lot of the time but that doesn't
need to happen
when you have manscapes lawn mowers 3.0
this is the most highly advanced men's
uh pube trimmer of all time
okay it's got technology that reduces
any grooming accidents by a whole
hell of a lot and lucky for me it's time
for me to harvest
some pubes because as you might have
heard
i am saving up for a special
world record stunt but that's neither
here nor there
what you need to do is make sure that
you
are groomed and ready for the ladies so
you're gonna go to manscaped.com
stevo and that's going to get you 20 off
your order
plus free shipping and that counts for
all customers in america
canada australia and the uk
how about that so once again for 20 off
your order
and free shipping to all of those
countries go to manscaped.com
stevo yeah dude
ah yeah i got nailed real early
with by jack nicholson i was uh i was
i was at this party in hollywood
and uh uh lou weather we had just signed
with lou out there
in fact i think we had a record out then
yeah we did
and uh yeah so cheech and i were the the
new kids on the block you know where the
new the latest thing
and we went to a party uh at lou others
and there was
uh everybody the stones were there and
half the beatles were there
and all these famous people jack
nicholson wow
and so i wanted to get i smoke a joint
so i asked lou you know where can i
smoke it he's all going to bedroom
so i go in the bedroom and there's i
looked at and
you know i light up the joint i look
down and there's john lennon
sitting on the floor by the bed
and i look wow john lennon
hey so i immediately offered him the
joint he goes oh no no i can't smoke uh
we got immigration problems you know and
so
just then the door opens in income rod
stewart
and he's over there and he's combing his
hair
in the mirror you know so they offered a
toke and he said
you know my voice i can't do that and so
then i
and anyway it smelled really rank you
know
so i put it out and then i walked down
into the hallway
and run into jack nicholson and
wow and i just saw him in a movie the
last detail
and in the movie he plays like a major
or something anyway
but there was one scene that fascinated
me i i
couldn't get over it where he's in the
mirror and he's combing his hair
and the the the scene went on for a long
time
and he's got no hair he's got a little
military cut
and but he he kept combing it throughout
the whole scene
and was it was mesmerizing you know so i
asked jack
you know i didn't say a big fan or
nothing nice jack that scene you know in
the in the last detail man
you're combing your hair you know with
your comb in your hair
it's taking forever and and you got no
hair to comb and
you're still combing it you know and i
said
was that i had liv did you make that up
on the spot or was that in the script
and he said he just looked at me like i
just
dump put a dump on his shoe you know
and he walked by me excuse me you're in
my way yes
pushed me aside and just just walked
away
it was it was a big yep
it was it
stopped me from talking like i knew
these people
you know jesus i i uh
have a thing with with the meeting
celebrities at least i used to
where i would develop like what i call
tourette's syndrome i would just say
something to a celebrity that was just
the worst
thing like i remember meeting mark
wahlberg
i went up to him and i said i said hey
man uh
i was at the the the screening for your
for your movie rock star i was like man
that movie
sucks i said i said
who thought that was a good idea even on
paper
oh my god i know i was all wasted and uh
and he said it was actually a very well
written script and i said yeah about the
douchebag that rudin
that ruined judas priest holy [ __ ]
yeah dude so i don't know well that's
the way to do it
no no seriously because now he's got
respect for you
yeah i got gas yeah that's true you
can't you don't want to be too nice
yeah yeah i met um
dave matthews so i said i said oh dave
matthews dude
man sometimes uh i'm in the van with all
with all the guys
and i got my ipod on shuffle and then
you pop up and it's so embarrassing for
me man
but dude i love your music
that's hilarious yeah oh man
so now john tommy um
the uh like smoking marijuana you're
kind of branded
to marijuana i see you're wearing a
tommy chong's cannabis
uh you know top right there he's the
maharishi of marijuana
yeah right because i mean if you think
uh you know nowadays
people who are prolific who are known
for for being potheads like snoop dogg
willie nelson i mean as willie nelson
goes back a ways
uh seth rogen seth rogen yeah but
my question is was there anybody
with a public profile like a real like
you know celebrity status who
openly identified as a
marijuana smoker in the media before you
a couple a couple um
trying to think of his name the actor
uh i think i have some potheads
maybe jack i think it'll it'll come his
name will come
steve mcqueen great star uh yeah steve
steve was uh definitely a pothead
more of a mortar he used to ride around
with bruce lee and smoke joints with
bruce lee i read in his biography
it was pretty interesting the uh bruce
lee the
the fighter yeah the yeah he there's a
part in steve mcqueen's doc uh
book where he said that him and him and
bruce lee used to drive around the
hollywood hills and they're convertible
and smoke weed together
oh yeah yeah yeah there was
a lot of celebs yeah there was there's a
few what's his name he's an
actor he got a year in jail for a joint
for one joint wow and he had he got a
year in jail
he was uh oh come on what's his name
very famous guy a very sexy
i think what we're the the answer we're
getting is no
dude no but nobody anybody that's other
than me
yeah nobody uh you know you know i got
turned on by jazz musicians you know
and like you know back in the day you
know that
the reefer uh louis armstrong
was it was a big pothead
and back in you know during nixon time
and nixon was a big louie armstrong fan
and so one time louie was on this world
tour
and so nixon sent air force one to pick
him up
you know to bring him home and and so
louie
wherever he would go he would collect
weed
you know because you couldn't get the
good weed like you know
the kind that you you can get over it
like in india and africa and that so
so louie uh had a big satchel
of this good weed from uh i guess it's
from india
somewhere and and he
he had had it with him and he carried
with him wherever he was and
air force one so he didn't have to worry
about immigration you know
[Laughter]
so so nixon gets on the on the on the
on the plane and uh meets
louie and so louie gets to get off the
plane
and he's got his bag and and nixon goes
here i'll carry that for you
[Laughter]
oh my god that's so fantastic
okay props
that's so cool unbelievable
but when you say nixon era good
weed how would that exact weed that
you're talking about stack up against
the [ __ ] that they have today
the what they have to do the the weed
the weeds
doesn't even compare it'll be like dirt
or just like that yeah
that they had like weed got marijuana
got like considerably more powerful over
the years
do you think yeah
now it's like a hundred percent well
right right right so i mean
wow well yeah yeah i mean i mean it it's
all a
chemistry yeah right you can so you can
get
i mean we have the same we weed hasn't
changed
the plant's the same as have been uh in
the beginning
as it is now you know there's no there's
no difference
what so you're telling me that you
smoked real kind
what's that you uh you're telling me
that you smoked real
dank kind bud way back in the 70s
the best the best from thailand
thai stick they call it or for or the
hash
see hash see that's what they that's
what the civilized people did
back in india in those places they would
take the best of the best
weed the pollen and then they would
condense it down
and they call them temple baubles and
the reason they call it temple balls is
that when they harvested
the weed for the hats they didn't cut
the plants down
they waited let the plants mature on the
vine
and then they would go through there and
the pollen would
just stick to their leather or their
naked bodies
and then they would come back into this
room and scrape off the pollen
off their bodies and that's what they
would make hash out of
and the the most delicate of the the
best of the best
would go to the top of the temple of the
of the room and that was for the temple
and and so they would scrape off that
the hash and make balls out of that
and those were temple balls and now
now when you have that you have a tiny
tiny little bit it'll put you away for a
week
if you're not careful six to 12 months
you know it's a big fallacy you know i
mean
i think i think high times in the
cannabis cup
they started a lot of these rumors you
know because
they would hey oh my weed stronger has
got x
x percent more uh thc and all that
but yeah same as the mexican wheat only
difference with
the mexican weed is that they never
cleaned it and they never
separated it so you had seeds and stems
and seeds and
then they'd put a sugar or dirt or
something to make it heavier
so they could sell you know so they make
the weight yeah
and and so so a lot of times you're
smoking stem
seeds weeds you know but but the actual
plant itself has not changed in
in thousands of you know it can't
it's a it's like i mean you can grow
bigger apples
right but the apples that they grew back
in the day even though they were smaller
they were
juicier and more more nutritious
you know than the phony ones they got
now so the weed
uh you know people like to think you
know they got oh
we got this this dank or this
uh chronic stuff
forget it man wow man the stinking joint
i was is since it wasn't since emilia
but it was uh
it was mexican and since to me it just
means without seeds
not that soft and and the stuff we used
to smoke had seeds
in fact it was a ritual where you clean
the weed
on an album cover and and then you
collect the seeds one time i i have my
house in bel air remodeled and i use
hippie
labor and so the hippies when they were
there they smoked
a couple of pounds of weed and they
cleaned it and they left the seeds
at my house and so the my house the guy
that was looking after my house he was
italian from italy uh
he found the seeds and so i had an area
in my yard that went up the hill and it
had an actual spring
and so he planted all the seeds up there
i had a i had he had over 40 plants
up there in bel air and they grew to be
15 feet
tall and the best oh the
juiciest bud and the neighborhood the
neighborhood kids got a whole
wind of it you know and so this one kid
used to sneak in the yard and
and steal the some of the bud
and so frank is like i say he was from
italy
frank he saw that that was happening so
he stayed up there one night
with his gun he had a gun a handgun
and the kid comes and steals the weed
and he's
trying to make it away and frank got him
from behind
hey you you must stop you stopping you
dropping that bag or i'ma shoot
you in the ass
[Laughter]
if anybody knows about getting shot in
the ass it's me
and you know what else i know just about
everything
about my body my health and my fitness
why because i wear a whoop band
what is it it's only the most
sophisticated
fitness tracking device out there it
works with
a subscription and an app which
tells you everything there is to know
like for example
sleep last night i was
in bed resting from 1205 am to 8 32
a.m now that sounds like i got eight and
a half hours of sleep
but thanks to my whoop app i know that i
actually slept for
seven hours and 11 minutes i know
precisely how many disturbances i had
i know that my rem sleep wow i got an
hour and 52 minutes of rem sleep perhaps
that's why my recovery is so high today
meaning that i'm ready for some serious
strain and when i get ready for strain
that might mean that i jump on my new
bicycle and you know what happens when i
get on my new bicycle
this automatically tells me
congratulations you went for a bicycle
ride
it knows everything it knows everything
about my heart rate variability
about my calories burned i mean i'm
telling you
i love it and i never take it off
because i never have to the battery just
slides right on there to charge it
oh you've got to try it you'd be crazy
if you didn't and if you love this
podcast
you will you'll go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p dot com
use the promo code stevo and you get 15
off at checkout so support the podcast
get healthy and know everything that's
going on with your body
by going to woop.com using the promo
code stevo
and enjoying 15 off at checkout now
let's talk about shooting people in the
ass
when you tell a guy where you're gonna
shoot him how you know
that's that's when it gets serious the
guy kid dropped the bag
and he ran and so the next day frank
told me about that and so i said
you know this is dangerous you know i
don't want anybody getting killed over
my weed
and so i went down to the prank told me
where the kid came from
and as i walked up to the house there's
a loud rock and roll music playing you
know
when i knocked on the door the music
stopped
and then the dad came to the door and i
said
he said yeah can i help you i said yeah
i said listen tell your kid to stay out
of my yard don't be
don't be stealing weed you know
stealing my plants he said what is it
what what plants are these
is he stealing as uh marijuana he said
isn't that illegal
and i said yeah i said that's another
reason why he should stay away from
my plants and the father goes i'll tell
them
wow that's great and that was the end of
that yeah
hey tommy sorry to cut you off yeah go
for it i'm curious so after
you know cheech and chong blew up in the
70s and 80s and and
and you're killing it and how do you tre
i mean
are you getting stopped at every airport
you know because people think that you
have weed on you at all times or was
there kind of like a method to traveling
at times at times yeah you know and now
it's okay but
yeah before oh yeah yeah but what i
would do
you know i always just carry a little
personal stuff you know a couple of
joints
uh if that but i always had it in my
guitar
case and i'd put my guitar on my back
and
and so the the weed would be above my
head
and so when the dogs came they'd sniff
around they'd find nothing
but one day i forgot i had a pipe in my
pocket
and so i was coming into canada
and the dog boom hit the pipe sat down
and so the narcs come over and they okay
you got any weeds and blah blah yeah
oh yeah and so i told them so so they
took the weed
and they searched my stuff and then they
left and they came back
with my passport and everything and they
said okay you can go
and i says uh what's up he said well
uh you're born in canada so we can't
keep you out of canada
and you're united states uh citizens so
you can't they can't keep you out of the
states either
and so i said oh you mean i can smuggle
weed
and the guy goes oh don't do that
but but but but now no now it's okay
yeah we got stop the last time we got
stopped we
you know everything's legal and we're in
detroit
and it's legal medically you know and so
we're coming home and
my son was with me paris and he had a
big
knapsack and there's a big jar these are
great buds and
he had it in his knapsack and then we're
going through the x-ray of course the
big jar shows up and
and the tsa guy goes uh whose bag is
this
and my son you know it's mine stand over
there
and so they brought out the bag opened
it saying it's weed
and so my son right away he said oh
that's my dad
he's he's he's old and he's got cancer
and this is medicine and because it's a
medical thing
yeah we had a biggest laugh because
going in
it was his week but when he got caught
[Music]
for sure it happens every time yeah but
the cops
the cops they they came they waited for
the cop to come and the cops said that
let them go and they said what about the
weed give it to him
yeah let him go and so we told him we
were gonna
we had a medical card you know i never
had one but
we got one real easy and then we sent it
to the cop and that's it
but now now i have no but i don't i
don't i don't
ever first of all we haven't been
playing for forever and
and i never no sense in carrying it
anywhere now because it's everywhere you
go there's weed
there's no problem unless you go to the
eastern hemisphere
you got a problem going through
singapore and
you know like uh india you know like
a lot of places it's tough to get away
yeah
i'll tell you a trick i'll tell you a
trick you go through those
eastern places where the hat
of the country that you're going to go
or leave
okay be that tourist you know the
tourists were whether you got the cowboy
hat
on or the or the vietnamese hat on
i found out accidentally because i i
collect hats you know so i had this
hat on and as soon as they saw the hat
they they point at it and they smile
you know i'm one of those you know yeah
so you so you connect
the worst thing you can do is be that
that bored american
you know right yeah you know that shitty
american but you want to
put on the put on the garb you know
wherever you go
whatever you know the tourist thing that
they sell because when you when you do
that you send a message that
you're one of those goofs that buy that
[ __ ]
yeah and that's what they like you
should try that in singapore steve
yeah wow well i was i was going into
japan uh this was a few years ago
and you know they're very strict super
strict and you don't lie to them
and so i'm coming in i got a a rap sheet
because i got busted for
bongs and so i
i had to put it on there have you ever
been arrested or
busted for drugs and i put yes but
i was with my wife who's very gorgeous
and very well
dressed and i was wearing my rolex at
the time
and i was well dressed and so they come
in
so the immigration you know they lead me
in and they he
took one look at me and my wife and he
says okay
you're going you you lie you lie
he told you to lie yeah he said you lie
and then when you come back you lie
again
no no drug no conviction nothing you've
got you go
that's great yeah because they they want
the tourists you know
you know they don't want those you know
long-haired hippie
you know that's going to take money from
them
right they want tours that are going to
dump money there you know
right i think to them it's all how you
address
perception yeah yeah what what's your
take on uh
them decriminalizing drugs and organ
they just you know drugs all drugs yeah
makes sense
it makes sense because you fill up the
you know a lot of junkies especially in
vancouver
in vancouver you know i mean jail is a
place to get a meal and a you know in a
warm place to sleep
you know and so they don't mind being
busted
you know i mean they're junky they're
sick people yeah
you know just like be busting people
that have the the
virus well you got the virus okay lock
them up you know
it's it's a sickness and and it's worse
than the virus because it's an addiction
sickness anytime you see a guy laying in
the gutter
with a needle sticking in his arm you
know that it's not his
choice of lifestyle right it's something
he has to do
you know i know i grew up in vancouver i
mean
it's a more i can't i can think of more
people
on one hand that that made it through
without dying of
of an overdose because it's insidious
you know yeah heroin i had a chance
i started i started hanging with lenny
bruce's uh
crew after lenny died there was a crew
his mom included sally marr and tony
bascaratoni
was his his lenny bruce's father-in-law
but tony was also the guy that
that got him the drugs you know that was
his job
and so one day i asked tony because we
became good friends
when he saw cheech and chong so i asked
tony i said what's
what's the big d because he was a heroin
addict i said what's
what's the big attraction to heroin
and he didn't see anywhere you just
reached in his pocket and had it be a
packet of heroin try for yourself
yeah i put that packet and hid it in my
sock drawer you know my in my clothes
but in my closet and then a month later
i went and got it out
and flushed it down the toilet i did not
want to
i don't want i don't want to know yeah
i i don't want to know there's no upside
right yeah that could have been the
changing point of your life
you know yeah yeah i gotta say but but i
learned see i got addicted
the trick is to get addicted to the
right things yeah you know
i got addicted i got addicted to
bodybuilding
you know all right that was that's my
i'm still addicted to it
you know and and that's that's the
perfect thing because it gives you the
same
high as you get from everything else you
know
uh because all it is really is is you're
you're you're working your body
in in such a manner that you have to
have endorphins
flood your body you see and it's the
endorphins that gives you the high
so that's at the runner's high that's a
runner's eye it's endorphins
if you want the same kind of thrill
stand on like a
five-story building on the edge and look
over
and all of a sudden your body just boom
gets filled up with endorphins
because it's anticipating you jumping
off and
and and so the body will protect you
within with these pain-killing uh
natural drugs
you see and and that's what real heroin
is that's what
heroin just takes away feeling you know
it deadens the nerves and so you get
this
euphoric feeling the trouble is when it
wears off then all of a sudden oh
dude you know like when you
ever had your arm asleep and then also
the blood
comes back in and oh and everything's
sore yeah
no no the best addiction to me is is
like
make it healthy make it healthy you know
i'm
interested to know what your opinion is
about whether marijuana
is an addictive thing to some people
yeah that's a good answer yeah just some
people just some people yeah
of course it would be it's that feeling
yeah i i'm addicted but i'm not
physically addicted
right you know like i can take it or
leave it
you know right it doesn't matter to me
right you don't get physical withdrawals
without it
no but there's like a habitual addiction
yeah last night was weird for me i'm i'm
doing what i'm doing now you know i'm
doing my fan mail
and all of a sudden i found this like i
was
high on something
and i i you know sometimes i don't
remember
you know especially with the virus with
the virus you know every once in a while
go oh wow am i getting that virus then i
realized
oh no i smoked out
that's like so so last night
i said oh i i
i couldn't walk i was sort of falling
over
you know and because i i practiced a
tango walk that's
that's my exercise it was a special way
to do a tangle walk
and excuse me
and so uh bless you so i couldn't figure
out you know
i had lost my balance and i and i know i
didn't get
high and i couldn't figure out what it
was so i said well i better get high
then i'll know as i smoked up and i got
too high and when i get too high
it's betty by his time
and so i went to bed went to bed had a
nice sleep woke up
fine everything's fine but it's
uh yeah
you know being a bodybuilder
i learned a lot about diet and about my
body
and uh it's it's cool
you know what what what i really used it
for
now is the spiritual side
i've been smoking and meditating
not so much meditating thinking
yeah thinking in fact in fact i haven't
meditated for a long time
you know because uh
i found out something you know that you
don't have to
all you have to do is it's your mind see
marijuana can
really affects the mind and the way it
does it puts you in the moment
you know and that's why whatever you're
doing in the moment
it's enhanced like if you're in the art
gallery for instance
all of a sudden you're you're seeing art
that you've never seen before
oh [ __ ]
oh i have another uh i i got another
uh thing to do at three what time is it
now
let's uh yeah let's let you go man but i
want to tell you tommy man
i don't think we've spoken to anybody on
this show
who has told us more captivating and
just
[ __ ] awesome stories man i've never
seen steve so quiet on the wild ride
podcast yeah this is great
dude it was uh really really special
is there anything that we can help you
promote
right now like uh you know the usual the
cbd
you know the atlanta cbds products that
i got out
you know they're they're doing really
well they're having a lot of
a lot of stores and they they're they
they help they help
help people that's what i like to do you
know i like to help people
but the the thing is about marijuana it
it keeps you on me anyway
uh boils things down to the essence
you know people the thing is about
meditation uh
it's good if that's what what you do you
know but
just like in in the christian bible says
you know that
you don't have to make uh repeat these
things over and over and over again you
know uh
as if you know the christian bible they
kind of talk bad about
repeating repeating uh mantras
you know uh yum yuho ring
yum you know okay yeah
all that really does is stop it's it
stops your
your mind from going other places you
know it keeps
gives your mind a bone to chew on but
all you have to do
that's what i tell everybody is
change your thought you can't have two
thoughts in your head at the same time
you think you can but you can't so
whenever trouble or anything arises
think of god that's the most powerful
thought you could have
and and that's it don't think of what
you need or what you want because
it's cool god will be uh
you know all you have to do is think of
god and and people said to me
you know when i did the movie against
god they said did you talk to god today
i said no i never talked to god
i only listen all right
okay i gotta go man dude what a treat
thank you so much tommy you're the best
you're the best thomas
brother peace man did i tell you
or did i tell you that was the
craziest experience man hearing those
stories from that icon
that legend tommy chong man i just am
beside myself with how much i enjoyed
that one and the whole
rest of the day i just told luck man we
had a great time talking to tommy chong
so you know what please get on the
instagram and post something tagging
tommy chong letting him know how much
you enjoyed it
and why don't you head over to amazon
and and put in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole because
i think we're actually doing pretty good
on there i saw something we were
ranked the number 30 top hot sauce
on all of amazon oh man let's see if you
can help me climb up that ladder
right go get yourself some stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole on
amazon and thank you for sticking around
man i really do appreciate you
yeah dude